chief Washington correspondent major
Garrett is with us major the highest
polling candidate on the stage last
night was Elizabeth Warren how did she
do so one thing I want to share with the
audience because we're gonna do this a
lot we should not be in the position of
acting like theater critics voters will
tell us what they thought over time so I
don't evaluate performances what is
interesting to me about last night is
Elizabeth Warren got five questions in
the first 40 minutes mm-hmm that
solidified the appearance of her being
the most important person on that stage
I noticed that two major if I was less
visible in the second hour but just that
prominence of getting that many
questions sort of signal to the audience
this is the most important person on the
stage whether she is or not we'll find
out one point I want to make about tough
C's Sister tweet about she did she said
is clear NBC wants Elizabeth Warren to
be the nominee I mean you're sort of
like saying wow why are they
structurally doing it this way one thing
to think about lots of reporters watched
those debates and come up with
performance analysis we actually talked
to people in Ames in Des Moines last
night and Amy Klobuchar who a lot of
reporters said didn't have a great night
they thought did very well Tulsi
gabbard's name came up you know the New
York Times said who Leon castro won the
night his name didn't come up at all in
Ames and Des Moines what that tells you
is voters look at this differently than
we do and if I learned anything in 2016
it's the reporters shouldn't tell the
country what's happening or what to
think about what just happened they'll
tell us over time wait for that process
to play out but we can't help but
they'll mean never ends but you're
making a good point and we're also
looking at it almost every day and
exactly this is it for many people that
was the first time they saw this I see
and and and the key about debates like
this especially early on is okay you
have a good moment what do you do it you
have a campaign infrastructure that can
take advantage of it can you raise money
can you put together better town halls
can you do something to use this as a
springboard that's the next stage for
every candidate does something at a
debate stage that stands out all right
major I will hold my question to the
eight o'clock power back with us for
much more now I'm scared to ask about
someone else to formulate my question to
the theater critic wave that is your
attack and I know you can do it all
right
we appreciate it